So if you whack your thumb with a hammer,
you think pain is in your thumb.
Physicians have a more
sophisticated understanding.
We know that it's an alarm
that goes, on nerves, to your spine,
where it is translated to your brain,
and pain actually happens ...
somewhere.
It's a little vague.
We actually only get
two days of pain education
throughout all of medical school, so ...
In fact, the only pain lecture
I remember from the '90s
was in a dark room like this,
after being awake for 30 hours and hungry,
and finding out our noon lecture
was sponsored by OxyContin.
We got pens, we got great lasagna,
and they had very cool slides
that showed pain stopped by opioids.
And we learned that home opioids
aren't addictive,
and if you stay ahead of pain --
(Laughter)
you can keep your patients pain-free.
And beyond the obviously
egregious marketing,
I think it was framing
"pain-free" as the goal
that has destroyed countless lives.
My friend's son Christopher
started having severe abdominal pain
during this "no-pain" era.
Eventually, he was diagnosed
with a colon disease
and had surgery his senior year.
They sent Christopher home
with 90 OxyContin,
and then 90 more,
and then, as the pain
started getting faster and faster ...
Uncontrolled pain is terrifying.
So when his ran out and his friends'
medicine cabinets ran out,
Christopher tried heroin.
And Christopher Wolf lost his battle
with substance use at age 32.
So did we misunderstand pain?
What if pain isn’t an alarm to silence
but a learning system for survival?
TED pose.
(Laughter)
(Cheers and applause)
Pain is every organism's primary
learning system for survival.
I mean, it's like,
"Ouch. Don't touch that."
Or, to paraphrase "The Princess Bride,"
"Life is pain, Highness."
"Pain-free" was marketing,
and it made physicians think
that one pill could solve pain.
It still makes people feel
like you can't be happy
if you have some pain,
and we now know
that if you want to move past
pain, it takes work.
Setting the bar
at "pain-free" was too high.
Plenty of people could have been
more comfortable,
but they gave up because pain-free
was out of reach.
We have really good new information
that I'm going to share,
and so from now on,
I want you to think about pain
as a Venn diagram,
with physiology, fear and control.
I'm going to tell you how each of these
can give you power over pain.
Right now, I'm translating
these, in my research,
into a low-back pain device
to reduce opioid use.
But 20 years ago,
I just wanted to have
a fast cure for needle pain,
for IV access and my kids' shots.
I was driving home one night
after a graveyard shift,
and my hands were vibrating
on the steering wheel,
because we needed
to get the tires balanced.
I was ignoring that to think about pain,
and when I got home
and reached for the door in my house,
my hand was numb.
Vibration.
So I burst in, my Boy Scout husband
grabbed some frozen peas,
and we had ourselves
a genuine eureka moment,
where cold and vibration blocked pain.
Over the next decade,
I found the right frequency to block pain,
I got a grant, and I created Buzzy,
which is vibration plus ice ...
in a bee shape.
And you put it on your arm
when you’re getting an injection.
And to date, 45 million
needle procedures had decreased pain,
and over 80 randomized controlled trials,
independently, all around the world,
have been published.
But ...
(Cheers and applause)
At about 30 randomized
controlled trials in,
one of my colleagues came to me
and confided that he was
in opioid recovery.
And he asked whether or not Buzzy
could let him get through
a total knee replacement drug-free.
I'd never thought about it.
It's the same pain nerve
for knees as for needles,
so I said maybe.
And he did it.
Vibration plus cold replaced OxyContin.
(Applause)
So at that point, I went all in,
to figure out why.
And here is what we know.
So the reason that vibration
decreases pain
is because the physiology of the nerves
of light touch, pressure,
stretching and motion
all races pain to the spine.
Now people have tried electricity
to trigger the light-touch nerves,
but we now know
that motion, shown in green,
is what's most effective
at shutting the gate on sharp pain.
This is called gate control,
and the exact right frequency of vibration
triggers the nerves that decrease pain.
The physiology of ice is different.
So the cold goes up to the brain,
where the conductor goes,
"Obnoxious, but not dangerous.
I will decrease sensations
coming from everywhere."
And it decreases pain everywhere.
If a child was so freaked out
from previous experiences
that even the swab hurt ...
physiology wasn't as helpful.
So we added distraction,
like a monkey poster.
And what we discovered
was combining counting
plus making a decision
cut pain in half.
So, for example, "How many monkeys
are actually touching the bed?"
activates the decision switchboard.
I know what you guys are doing. It's five.
(Laughter)
Here is your pain hack
for the day, though.
If you do not have monkeys on hand,
then find any sentence
and count how many of the letters
have holes in them.
Counting, deciding.
So, like, you've got a g-hole,
o-hole, a ... hole.
(Laughter)
(Laughter and applause)
I guarantee you
and your family will use this.
(Laughter)
The biggest hack, though,
is understanding why distraction works.
And now, through functional MRI,
we can actually see pain happen.
And it's not one place.
Pain is a symphony of connections,
from the sensation area to the conductor,
to the decision switchboard,
and then to fear, memory,
meaning, control.
So if the decision switchboard
is occupied sorting monkeys,
it can't notify fear and meaning,
and you feel less pain.
What you feel
is mostly what you expect to feel.
Stay with me.
If you're a kid,
the same punch hurts more from a bully
than from your buddy.
And if you're an adult
and you feel something,
the second you think it's cancer,
it hurts more and more,
until you find out it's not.
And those same kids
who had horrible shot experiences
can tolerate all kinds of needle pain ...
to look cool.
(Laughter)
Because it is a different context.
These patterns, called connectomes,
are very personal,
because experiences lay down
more of the same sensation.
And we now know that people who have
certain areas in the brain connected
feel more pain than people
with different areas connected.
And more importantly,
untreated pain or intense pain
can lay down heavier connections,
so that even when your body is healed,
you will still feel more pain.
It's this very plasticity
and personalization
which makes the physiology,
fear, control matrix so useful.
Because choosing physiologic options
that you can layer, that work for you,
decreases pain,
like heat, cold, vibration,
deep relaxation, acupuncture,
capsaicin, exercise, meditation ...
There's more.
Christopher probably had
10 of these around his house
and just didn't know it.
Having control over your options
decreases pain.
Deep breathing increases control.
Choosing what to focus on
increases control.
Fear and control
are the volume knobs for pain.
Fear controls so many of our sensations,
this shouldn't be unusual,
but we don't practice it for pain.
So if you're home alone
and you hear a clunk ...
your hearing becomes hypersensitive.
But when you remember
your kid's home from college,
your fear dials down
and your brain overrides it and says,
"Don't worry about it."
Saint Augustine called pain
the greatest of evil.
But if it is a survival system,
it cannot be all evil.
So instead,
think of pain as your nagging,
safety-obsessed, exaggerating friend
who’s sometimes wrong.
And it’s OK to ignore
or override your friend
if you know that you're safe.
This takes practice.
On a flight that was turbulent,
I had an entire cup of scalding-hot coffee
dumped straight on my ankle.
Electric jolt through my scalp.
I ripped off my sock; it was already red.
It was going to blister.
There was no way I could get my foot
into that little sink
to get cold water on it.
And then I remembered.
Physiology hack.
I had an unopened cold beer.
(Laughter)
Medical-grade cold beer
went on my ankle, stat.
(Laughter and applause)
I had a vibrator
in my carry-on, because I would.
On my ankle. And then --
(Laughter and applause)
The pain kind.
(Laughter)
And then my fear hack.
I'm like, "There's a barf bag
that has holy letters,
but I'm going to put it
in the pocket pouch and save it,
because then, I have increased control."
And, pain  ,
I was no longer that concerned.
(Cheers and applause)
Although then, I realized I'm that guy,
with my bare foot sticking out
in the aisle on a plane,
with a beer on it.
(Laughter)
Power over pain isn’t always pretty,
but it is possible
and it is absolutely critical.
Because there’s one more misconception
we have not talked about.
I honestly thought that opioids
turned off some pain switch.
They turn on our reward system.
So some people feel amazing,
but most people just still feel
pain, but don't care.
Now, this is a godsend for people
with chronic pain diseases.
We should not take them away.
And in the trauma bay,
the more morphine in the first 24 hours
after a burn or a wound,
the less post-traumatic stress,
the less chronic pain later.
But studies show
that recovery after surgery
is just as well accomplished
with coaching and physiologic options.
And if you're one of the people
who feel amazing with opioids,
it's too risky.
A study in 2019 found
that one in 15 young adults who got
opioids for their wisdom tooth removal
had substance-use disorder within a year.
Ibuprofen works better.
So what do we do?
Well, in my dream world,
we have health-care systems --
paid-for options and coaching --
for Christophers everywhere.
And we quit giving
double-digit prescriptions for opioids
for home recovery.
In the real world,
80,000 people died in the US last year
from opioid overdoses,
and 80 percent of substance-use disorders
start with a pill prescribed for pain ...
Usually taken from your friend's
medicine cabinet.
People can’t afford options.
Doctors, 20 years later,
still don't know them.
But you do.
You all now know to throw away
the opioids in your medicine cabinet.
You now know that there are options
you can use to decrease pain,
and you know that "pain-free"
should be ditched
for "more comfortable."
And whether you dump scalding coffee
or pain wakes you
and exhausts you every day ...
Options that are in your control ...
can allow you to reframe pain.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)
Whitney Pennington Rodgers:
Amy, thank you, it's amazing.
So how do you think
that pain scales have set us back
from this work that you're doing,
and how is the NIH treating pain
and addiction differently now?
Amy Baxter: So in one
of the 120 versions of this talk,
I talked about
how the thing is, in the '90s,
if we wanted to “disease-ify” pain,
it meant we had to be able to measure it.
So that was where the FACES
scales come from,
and they're actually very useful
in the emergency department
to tell whether or not
a medicine is working.
In fact, we were one of the first ones
that showed, with sickle cell,
that the patient's report,
based on those scales,
was what was most indicative
of whether they needed to be admitted,
rather than any biologic marker.
But what we're doing now
is we're using something
called the PROMIS scales,
so it’s how intense pain is
on five-point scales,
how much it interferes,
so there's pain interference,
pain intensity.
And the way we're looking at pain
is much more on the impact for the person,
rather than trying to pretend
there's any kind of objective
pain measurement.
WPR: OK.
And you mentioned that you're working
on some new applications for Buzzy,
specifically for back pain.
What are some of the possibilities
that we have here
for what this could do for us
in the future?
AB: On my tombstone,
there's going to be a vibrating bee.
It's actually called DuoTherm, not Buzzy.
But what we've learned
is that there are harmonics of interaction
between the specific frequencies
that cancel out the pain.
So there’s one particular nerve
called the Pacinian
that has a very specific frequency range,
and by causing them to interact,
we're starting to explore
more about the pain
that's coming from the fascia
between the skin and between the muscles,
but that area is where we're unexplored,
and so by interacting
with different frequencies
and then layering heat
or cold, pressure options,
giving people the choice
of so many different ways to do it,
it's really engaging
all the different areas of the brain
from which pain comes.
WPR: Wow, OK.
Well, thank you so much, Amy.
AB: Welcome.
Thank you, all.